[Music]
so there I was woke up with a heavy case
of amnesia in the middle of nowhere the
only clue to my past is Harry's name and
address inside this hat so I made my way
to the apartment and that's when I found
you I think your stapler gonna loosen a
shoe so you're tucking Pikachu with no
memories is addicted to caffeine I could
stop whenever I want these are just
choices another round extra shot I don't
know maybe Harry got in too deep and
mixed up the wrong crowd that kind of
thing you could talk to humans I can
talk to Pokemon and if you want to find
your pops we're gonna need no I don't
need a Pokemon what about a world-class
detective Harry is still alive case
closed
but still open until I solve it
all right here it is Harry faked his own
death or somebody else take Terry's
death
[Music]
Harry fake somebody else is dead that
last one doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt with this putz
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist that's very twisty
yeah no he's barely moving don't tell
him that
oh he's on a fight quick get in front of
him stop Oh No
he's going down hard Tim should have
worn a helmet
[Music]